[Music]
thanks a lot thanks a lot Conan you know
is really wonderful to be back here
after so many years I've been on this
show for fourteen times now and really
do enjoy being a part of it every every
time a few years ago a few people came
up to me and asked me a few questions
and I decline answer and and that's what
led me here today always do what's wrong
and that will give you much more leeway
in the future just in case you need any
leeway which barely any of us need I'd
like to tell a few jokes this is a joke
that my grandmother used to tell me
horse walks into a bar
bartender says it's probably not a good
idea that you're in here you're very
large animal any sudden movements you
may injure somebody I don't know why
you're here
none of the glasses are ergonomically
designed for you to drink from them so
you should probably leave
Panther walks into a gazebo that's it
alright so um there's a there's a few
things that a few people have told me
one my grandfather once said this to me
I don't know why and Carol Burnett one
time I looked at me in the eyes and I'll
never forget that so I'd like to do I'd
like to do a few uh few little uh little
ditties for you I got this one this one
now this one's from New York City I got
I come from New York I don't for you
guys any from New York or whatever yeah
ok
Conan used to be in New York used to be
New York and I I don't know but I'm back
so here I am but I'd like to do this so
check it out ok so I like to do this on
this adieu song ok so give it up give it
up give a love y'all give it off
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know what got into me that was
really not appropriate and there's a far
classier show than that so what I mean
to say is that I had an amazing time on
tour with Conan and I'm so appreciative
of that and I decided to write a song
and I'd like to perform it for you with
your good graces here tonight something
like this
1 2 3
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you